Well, I think that trade is an important issue.
Of course, we are 5% of the world's population,...
...we have to trade with the other 95%.
And we need to have smart, fair trade deals.
We also, though, need to have a tax system...
...that rewards work and not just financial transactions.
And the kind of plan that Donald has put forth...
...would be trickle-down economics all over again.
In fact, it would be the most extreme version,...
...the biggest tax cuts for the top percent of the people in this country...
...that we've ever had.
I call it "Trumped-up, trickle-down" because that's exactly what it would be.
That is not how we grow the economy.
We just have a different view about what's best for growing the economy,...
...how we make investments that will actually produce jobs and rising incomes.
I think we come at it from somewhat different perspectives.
I understand that.
You know, Donald was very fortunate in his life and that's all to his benefit.
He started his business with $14 million borrowed from his father...
...and he really believes that the more you help wealthy people,...
...the better off we'll be and that everything will work out from there.
I don't buy that.